if the movies good enough the effects
won't matter you look back at the
original King Kong and you can tell
that's like a puppet but the movies so
good you don't care you really feel for
that damn puppet when it falls off the
Empire State Building at the end a
practical effect is anything that
primarily exists there on the set the
actors can interact with them and they
have a real sort of gravity and feeling
to them that computer effects can often
lack kind of the first big movie that
had a lot of visual effects in it was
the 1924 version of the movie The Thief
of Bagdad which has all these incredible
creations and and concoctions and
on-screen tricks that make it seem like
there's actual magic going on when
obviously there isn't the heighth of
practical effects for me is probably the
late 70s and 80s
[Music]
the best special effects are probably in
the original Jurassic Park that was the
height of practical effects and also
kind of the start of computer effect and
for the most part they still hold up in
a way that a lot of other
computer-generated effects of the air at
Dome
I think the trend away really was kinda
in the late 90s you look at something
like the matrix
it's definitely sort of this watershed
where people were like oh we can use
computers to make things look really
cool and then Hollywood just overdid it
I don't think computer effects are all
bad necessarily but they certainly have
sort of a feeling to them that they
don't exist in any physical reality
whatsoever and that creates kind of a
disconnection between the movie in the
audience now in the Hobbit movies where
the story doesn't work as well I found
myself really distracted especially in
the most recent one by these gigantic
moments of battle that have no real
feeling of like weight to them of the
characters like behaving as physical
beings in a universe in particular
there's a scene where Legolas runs up a
crumbling staircase as it's falling out
for beneath him it takes you out of the
movie because it's so ridiculous the
primary argument for practical effects
is a storytelling one it forces you to
zero in on what you really want to do I
think that practical effects necessarily
limit you by what is physically capable
for actors in a certain situation
you